full disclosure I'm a bit of a tell-tale
fan I wasn't sold on Minecraft or Game
of Thrones but I was pretty into the
wolf among us Walking Dead and tales
from the borderlands now telltale are
doing Batman and episode 1 felt like a
surprisingly good start for the Dark
Knight what's particularly interesting
is the new features telltale have
introduced but first up I think I'd
better tell you about everything in
Batman that's the same as you'd expect
telltale it's using the same engine and
their tried-and-true format that Divis
up your time between QuickTime events
having a chat exploring contained
environments and making choices that
range from trivial matters to grant
dilemmas you can shape Bruce Wayne's
persona much like you did with Lee and
Big B and just like in The Walking Dead
and wolf among us your protagonist will
occasionally flip his [ __ ] when you
select an option that you had expected
will be delivered jokingly or
sarcastically enjoy drinking my wine
it's worth more than most of you know
easy skidding everyone nope bad worse
luckily much like other telltale games
the characters are well fleshed out the
plot is quite involving and I actually
found myself really really concerned
with disappointing Alfred so what's
different well if you're into cosmetic
changes the first thing you can do in
the game is pick from four bat tech
colors luckily for you and me it gets a
lot more interesting from there instead
of fumbling about the place and missing
quick time events your failure to hit
directional buttons in a timely manner
only results in you being unable to
top-up your bat meter and land a
finishing move so even those with slow
reflexes will get a near-flawless back
on that experience while that might seem
like a cop-out it wouldn't make much
sense for Batman to be fumbling with his
gadgets and getting beaten up by
henchmen some of my favorite parts of
tells her games are when they borrow
mechanics from traditional
point-and-click adventure games Batman
has a similar vibe to the wolf among us
in that you'll be doing quite a bit of
investigating unlike Big B however
Batman's detective time is spent
investigating crime scenes and then
linking pieces of evidence together
which amount to a holographic conclusion
that plays out whatever went down
this actually works surprisingly well
and adds an element of puzzle solving
that feels right at home in this kind of
game and setting in typical Batman
fashion your Batcave and gadgets are
pretty awesome you'll use your gadgets
in combat a lot and your Batcave is
outfitted with a codex you can access
which gives you a constantly update and
who's who of the people and places that
matter you can also log into a Gotham
media feed to check out the
repercussions of all the stupid
decisions you made this is an
interesting addition as telltale games
usually have you adventuring from place
to place not having what is essentially
a base to return to and finally if you
have friends who like to weigh in on
your stupid decisions like my dudes
Adela's gotten better this time around
and added crowd play now your friends in
the same room can weigh in on what
decisions they think you should make and
then judge you for making them with a
thumbs up chord down
of course we're only an episode in so
how much these features pop up in later
episodes and what else lies in store for
us remains to be seen but for me
personally I always like to see telltale
trying new things and this is a
promising bad start
you